Make sure you've got your Power Glove equipped
and a memory card handy.
We unlocked a few long-hidden secrets in our
earlier video, 7 Gaming Easter Eggs that Weren't
Discovered for Years.
Well, we dug up five more gaming goodies that
remained hidden for longer than anyone would've
guessed.
Mortal Kombat's Secret Menus
While feeding the Mortal Kombat trilogy all
of our quarters during the early '90s, few
suspected that the arcade versions had a back
door to a secret menu made by series co-creator
Ed Boon.
To get in, you had to hit the Block button
on the Player One and Player Two sides in
a specific order.
Then you'd be able to run diagnostic tests,
keep track of how many coins the machine had
taken, and watch each character's ending.
The secret menus in Mortal Kombat 3 even allowed
you to unlock hidden features, watch a Fatality
demonstration, or play a secret Galaga-type
game.
Donkey Kong's Hidden Initials
An arcade legend since its debut in 1981,
Donkey Kong was so popular it was ported to
the Atari 400 and 800 consoles.
Landon Dyer, who worked on the port, blogged
in 2008 that he hid an Easter egg in his version
of the game.
Over a year later, gamer Don Hodges finally
found it.
First, play through the game and reach a new
high score between 33,000 and 33,900.
Then kill off your remaining lives, with your
final death by falling.
Set your difficulty to four, and after the
game loads the intro, you'll see Landon Dyer's
initials on the title screen underneath the
Nintendo copyright.
After 28 years, who knew that Donkey Kong
still had an utterly useless trick up his
hairy sleeve?
GoldenEye's in-game emulator
Seventeen years after GoldenEye: 007's Nintendo
64 debut, one fan found something hidden deep
within its code: an in-game emulator with
ten working games.
The emulator includes Sabre Wulf, Atic Atac,
Jetpac, Lunar Jetman, Alien 8, Gun Fright,
Underwurlde, Knight Lore, Pssst, and Cookie—all
titles that GoldenEye's developer, Rare, made
for the ZX Spectrum console in the 1980s.
Serious Sam, zero encounters
There's a hidden level called "Sacred Yards"
in Serious Sam: The First Encounter, which
usually requires lots of running-and-gunning.
Years after its release, one player found
that you could skip much of the Yards by exploiting
bugs and shooting certain objects.
That got the interest of YouTuber SolaisYosei,
who contacted the game's lead designer, Roman
Ribaric, for answers.​​ Ribaric suggested
using a level editor to unlock the game's
secrets.
That allowed SolaisYosei to record a perfect
playthrough—14 years after the game launched.
And finally...
Super Beanstalk Brothers
After more than 30 years, people are still
finding secrets for the first Super Mario
game—like this one.
Pay attention, it's kinda complicated:
In a two-player game, let Mario die at World
1-2, then progress Luigi up to World 5-2.
There, proceed to the second Hammer Brother.
There's a hidden beansprout in one of the
blocks.
Let Luigi die from a hammer throw while climbing
the vine.
If done correctly, Mario will spawn at World
1-2 with a vine sprouting next to him.
You can use the vine to keep hitting the Buzzy
Beetles near the start of the level, spawning
1-ups until you reach the maximum number of
extra lives.
Weird, right?
Okay, well, not as weird as this…
"Alright!
Yay!"
Nothing's as weird as that.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
video game Easter egg is your favorite...